State lawmakers grilled Clark County
School leaders today in Carson City
regarding that altercation between a
student and a school police officer we
thank you for joining us at five I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis
school officials citing the ongoing
investigation into the matter to avoid
answering direct questions Joshua
paguera joining us in studio tonight
with an update for us Joshua yeah hello
Brian Denise the superintendent at
school police chief were asked to
testify before in a joint session of two
Senate committees where troubled
lawmakers is the district's policies
when dealing with kids
I come from the perspective that if
students are fighting
rather than giving them a citation or
arresting them maybe we should provide
them with the mental health support
services that they need several state
senators grilled school police chief
Mike blackeye over his Department's
reported use of force Senator Fabian
donate asked how many officers were
investigated for excessive force on
students in the last three years a
neighborhood of five and carriages for
clarification so that is five that you
have investigated for use of force my
guess is is that would be five for
excessive use of force and have do you
know from the top of your head if any of
them have been terminated or were most
of them resulting in suspension or
what's or it's just that's just a number
for investigation that's the number for
investigation
the the outcome of the investigation is
not public The Exchange led to Chief
black guy to ask for a bathroom break
and recess at the center of today's
proceedings in Carson City the
altercation that happened last month in
Durango High School an officer was
captured on video grabbing a student
from the back taking him to the ground
and placing a knee on the student's back
community members attended the hearing
to testify on the matter these are
things that are issues that are
continuing to plague and and continue to
confront our communities and and you
know to be honest with you man we're
just tired of it CCSD released these
numbers pertaining to use of force the
last three years you can see there's
been a decrease in school police using
their pepper spray on students
CCSD police say the number of fights
between students is on track to decrease
compared to the previous 2021-2022
school year but the number of individual
acts of violence like battery and
assault is up Denise Joshua thanks for
that update we can also tell you that
the hearing is still ongoing we have a
link on our website if you would like to
listen to the rest of it